hey guys welcome back to the evident
caitlyn podcast yeah no fancy it you
know we're just simple people simple
intros but today we're talking about a
very complex and tangled situation which
is comparing youtube verse blogging yes
you guys if you listened to our last
podcast episode we talked about our
history with blogging how that's
actually kind of the thing that set us
on the path to youtube and we went down
some like nostalgic memory lane type
type things with the blog but yeah we
did it like i was like almost a
part-time hobby but with like
significant effort for three years yeah
yeah part-time part-time hobby with
significant significant with like hidden
hopes that it would like just blow up
and would become our bloggers or
something but I think because those two
experiences the blogging and now the
YouTube and yeah we spend about equal
time doing both if you think about it
cuz we've been doing YouTube for the
years now well and at the same time
during our youtube career we were
continuing to blog also we put
significant we put significant effort
into some blog post we did on some on
some on some infer for the very
beginning of our youtube career we were
putting a significant effort into every
single one of our blog posts but I guess
that's not the point I mean the point
I'm making is we've spent about equal
time yeah in both worlds and had very
different experiences and even though
there might like like aiya I have heard
from some people the sentiment of like
oh blogs are dead I don't necessarily
think that cuz I still see a lot of
successful blogs out there but for us
blog and I think think it'd be
interesting to talk about our
experiences blogging their personal
experiences tube and like our thoughts
on both they're different they require
different skills they require different
allocations of time both have potential
but they're just they're just that is
very different so today we're going to
talk about some others
those differences some of like the
experiences we've had with each and kind
of contrasting them and telling some
stories of like experiments we've done
with blogging and and everything like
things that we haven't really shared
like how we tried to outsource the
writing of our blogs that one time and
experiments and that was after we had
started the YouTube channel and we still
wanted to try to keep up the blog doing
more detailed tutorials for all of our
projects and we just didn't have the
time to so we were like a lot of blogs
hire ghost writers yeah what if we you
know we're we're just trying to do
tutorials for our projects written
tutorials they can take what we've done
in the video and just translate it to
written form oh it did not work what
does not work well we never posted we
hired some people we got their work we
paid them for it and we decided not to
post it because multiple people multiple
people yeah we tried this multiple times
and it was just like it didn't feel like
us it was I think we did publish one eye
heavily edited one I didn't feel good
about it I didn't like it I was I I felt
like I had to like make it worth
something so I heavily edited it but it
still didn't sound like cast I still
don't don't like I don't know yeah I
mean maybe I'll see if I can find it
again I don't know I don't know I was we
have a lot of things we've posted over
over the years but it yes we tried
multiple services we tried multiple
people but I think when you're just
writing when your video is just a very
basic tutorial like step one step two
step three step four and everything is
very clear it's easy to translate that
but a lot of our content is us having
fun messing around and doing experiments
and it's hard to translate that and uh
like written tutorials and you you kind
of need to know like if we were gonna
write a blog post now and make it like
as good as we want to we would be
sharing like behind the scenes things or
things that then maybe make it into the
video or what have you but it just
doesn't make sense for us to put time
into that
because our website doesn't give use and
like a third person can't write that
yeah no no yeah it's just so much more
worth our time to just make another
video yeah which brings us to YouTube's
first blogging oh man I think that I
gave some stats and in our last podcast
but I'll like quickie runs elevant
numbers we have done now a hundred and
forty YouTube videos which to me is kind
of crazy and we have done about a
hundred and thirty blog posts we did it
was a hundred forty-eight YouTube videos
on our main channel and 136 blog post
yeah and we we know we have like there's
some overlap once we start doing YouTube
videos we did a blog post also but we
did we did we steadily blogged for a
long time and we not only steadily blog
but Kalyan put time energy effort I put
time and energy effort into the
infrastructure and one thing we didn't
mention in the last podcast is I did SEO
I installed plugins that like raided our
our our SEO we wrote the metadata we did
tons of research with like google
webmaster tools to see what search terms
people were coming to our blog for we
did Pinterest we didn't talk about the
last blog post we did like effort
independent scaling put so much effort
into Pinterest and we have I would
design custom pins like pinnable
images I would like to think about what
to write and we have attended thousands
of pins oh you are well our blog yeah we
made like a custom little pin it button
that would like pop up over our images
when you hover it over though yeah we
had like all this all this time and
energy and effort yet it really didn't
really didn't go anywhere and with all
of this with the blog with YouTube I
mean we recognize that our YouTube
channel growing and reaching the success
that it has we're lucky yeah we're
really I mean it could have totally been
the same thing with YouTube we we
somehow were plucked mm-hmm
no gods and shone around but that speaks
to a strength of YouTube
there's discoverability built into the
platform and that's one of the by far
biggest strengths of YouTube yeah I say
that even though even though I think it
it might I I think it might take more
effort to do it in my experience it
takes more effort to do one YouTube
video than it does to do one blog post
by far but I think it is much easier to
succeed on YouTube because of that
discoverability cuz there's no like
there's no website you go to and you're
like oh I wonder what blogs I might like
or might want to watch where there's an
algorithm feeding them to you there are
the two biggest search platforms in the
world number one Google number two
YouTube now lots of blogs the main way
that blogs find their initial growth and
success is through SEO and through like
networking and link linking and all of
the games that you play with Google to
show up on Google but that's very
different than an algorithm that is
built to keep you on platform and feed
you things that it has learned you will
probably like yeah and introduce you to
new thing Google is just serving
relevant results yeah they want their
searcher the people who are searching on
Google to find it like they're not
monetized incentive to like direct like
people to good content and in a way I
don't know well it's different because
Google is directing to everything the
internet and the competition is so high
the bar for SEO on on the internet on
the internet for like I like this is a
great example drywall repair if you are
searching for drywall repair on Google
oh boy how many companies are competing
for that number one slot that
yeah some local contractors drywall
repair company like maybe some tutorials
but like all of the big blogs with tons
of riders and the competition is killer
but when we made our drywall repair
YouTube video the the competition was
way less no YouTube still a big place
it's still way less than all of the
Internet and it's easier to stand out
and and it was when we started I mean
YouTube YouTube is being flooded all the
time more and more and more but it still
is easier to stand out on YouTube and
it's still a smaller pool than the
Internet at large you know yes yes yeah
but like the competition on Google
searches are it's just insane because
there's just so many more web sites out
there that there are YouTube videos I
don't know you're competing against more
yeah bloggers I think especially as you
go into like nice things in a way you
know like when people might not be
searching for it as much like her
industry this could vary a ton I'm not
fully sure like yeah for um gaming
content oh there's a lot of competition
on YouTube for gaming content but for
high quality drywall repair videos they
might not be as nuts you know but for
like on blogs on blogging websites it
might be the opposite like honestly when
when I am searching minecraft tutorials
there's a bajillion YouTube videos but
trying to find a well-written blog post
on like automatic chicken farms in
Minecraft there aren't that many vlogs
but but it also could just be because
Google isn't as good at like serving up
ones that you don't have as many links
pointing to them or don't have their SEO
David yeah there could be tons of blogs
out there doing minecraft chicken parm
tutorials or does not finding it because
they're on page 12 you know exactly so
so that you know there's there's a like
oh man on the on the blogging side of
things I was overwhelmed so many times
honestly like
looking at ways towards success yeah
well it was also like wow I mean and
YouTube is constantly updating
constantly changing too but I think like
with YouTube you know there would be
updates and it might just be like it
might result in you like tweaking your
content a bit in whatever way like when
people started doing longer videos
versus two-minute videos overtime that's
a change that has happened but like with
our website so much of the adjustments I
had to be made we're all like back-end
things that would have to be like jankle
II put together that's like when when
responsive web pages which are web pages
that change shape depending on if
they're on your computer or on your
phone when that started becoming a
requirement Google would penalize you if
you didn't have a responsive website and
if you don't have this metadata or that
tag or like like Facebook optimization
or like there's a bajillion thing that's
though all right things that would
literally [ __ ] your website whereas
like with YouTube it's it's not as easy
as you get to that like point of like
just crippling failure also it
simplifies things for you it's just like
make the content and upload it yeah and
there are a bajillion things fine things
like you got to do is title thumbnail
but you had to do that for blogs too
like writing titles that took a lot of
time even when we are blogging mm-hmm
choosing that like the female image yeah
or even things like oh this is getting a
little like beyond SEO but you know we
think a lot about the interest for our
YouTube videos because so many people
click out in those first few seconds but
it was kind of the same with blogs like
we had to think of a really interesting
hook in the beginning yeah insert the
skit I wrote yeah but um it says yeah
there's like succeeding on websites
requires a different skill though I
think a lot of it is technical SEO
website stuff mm-hmm
and you also need a write good content
and be engaging at all of that stuff but
I mean like it's so much more
it's interesting yeah another thing
that's really interesting and I think
that you can speak more to this on the
blog side then I can talk about the
community aspect of blogs cuz I know
that you engage with other bloggers and
you'd be on other blogging websites did
like it was there like little pools of
like bloggers that would like yes did do
things in stock there were so there were
some uh kind of like communities of
bloggers that you could tell they were
just genuine friends and then there were
a lot of things that were kind of like
tricks to game Google like riding guest
posts on different blogs gonna like it
kind of like co.labs but I'll just get
into what they were so so there are some
things where like you would genuinely
like hear about a blog or a blog or from
someone else because they were like they
became in life or like real life friends
and they would do collabs and stuff and
that's how I found other bloggers
through young house love which is like
the main blog that I followed and that
always felt very natural but then there
are a lot of things where there would be
so some some examples are guest posts
but honestly I didn't see that many of
those and maybe it was just cuz I didn't
like them because you did yeah I would
skip it because like the reason that I
would read the blog it was partially the
content but more just about the person
if it was someone else I was like I
don't know who this person's I don't
care like I'm not reading because of the
tutorial you know what I mean yeah
things that would work sometimes would
be like roundups so there would be like
an event so like one common one is like
the one room challenge and I think
that's still going on where there's a
certain period of time and there's like
some bigger bloggers that are like
invited to officially be a part of it
one blog runs it some bloggers are
invited to be officially part of it but
then anyone can also join in and like
use the hashtags and stuff and but
hashtags how does that work on well
website
let me let me finish it's not just
websites anymore because this is when
it's still going on yeah
and so there will be a certain time
period a certain start and end date
where you have the challenge to like do
like make over an entire room in however
many days and everyone posts a blog post
about their room makeover on the same
day and then at the bottom of that blog
post first will have all the other like
official participants with like slightly
bigger thumbnails I was like their rooms
that they made over but then like a big
auto-generated list of other people
often and I don't know how they pulled
those other ones but in addition to that
like there's like hashtags so yeah
Instagram and stuff um so there's a lot
of things like that but it's interesting
that they had to go about and create
their own community system because web
pages aren't natively linked like
YouTube videos like like YouTube not to
be creepy or anything but YouTube knows
what you like based on what you watch
you know it's like if you watch a few of
these people and you share like and
those three people a lot of those their
subscribers watch this fourth person
then YouTube is like oh I know you like
these three you're gonna like this
person because of all of the data that
we've collected about everyone pushes
you in the direction that you might like
and like figure out how to do that
themselves
manually yeah manually and there is a
comment system on blogs and everything
obviously about like there is a comment
system so I I would comment sometimes on
blogs that I was reading um another
reason that like young house love stood
out to me is that sherry would always
reply like and she replied to everybody
the first time she replied to you where
you were like I still fangirl leave a
comment on one of her Instagram post and
she replies I'm like sherry replied to
me but so there was still ways to like
build community and I feel like they did
it really well I tried to model that
with our blog even though we would just
get like you know zero comma zero
to a few comments yes always reply to
people and I do think that's one thing
that we carried into YouTube and like we
still try our best to do but like so
many people that we you know started
developing rage relationships with or
just like we're keeping an eye on their
channels cuz they were in the same genre
as we were or whatever so many people
who were much bigger than we were when
we started but are smaller than like
where we are now we're already at the
point where they were like I don't
really well you know I'll reply to a few
and that's it um and I just remember
being like why did you know reply to
more people like just like engage their
community you know like and I still
really try to do that and I think it was
because of like my experience on young
house love and just being like it's
important to your community I think the
thing that shot ourselves in the foot is
when we started publishing we're going
from one video per week to sometimes
five videos per week every uncut - main
gaming we do the podcast every at two
weeks and then that the social media and
all the social media is in and we've
been blessed by a growing audience and
that's that's really cool I think we did
reply to every comment up until about
300,000 subscribers and then this got
away from us yeah it yeah kept up with
replying to everybody for a really long
time and we still we still honestly do
try to like reply to a large chunk of
especially on the first day yeah it's
just spread out across so many more
channels but I think that that is one
thing that I've I picked up from the
blogger community at least like the
blogs I hung out on yeah um yeah it was
much more of a like build your own
community I think another thing that's
interesting about creating on a blog
we're creating on a social media website
like YouTube
there's the main thing that we could do
I mean we do like we could talk about
Instagram and throw that in there and
everything but that's not that's not
like I think our main let's talk about
business things because we our business
is is YouTube I mean yeah we haven't
really monetized Instagram because the
earning potential on YouTube is bigger
for us and we just are out of time all
the time and anything anything extra for
us right now really no no I'm just not
gonna do it it's like I know we could be
like pushing and squeezing our assets
more but we don't want to we're just
we're just we're just done we were
trying to get efficient and and hit
things the best but um
whereas I go my a features all of these
social media websites they want you to
use it they want to add all these
features and like make it the best that
it can be for your blog it's all on you
yeah you need to choose your host you
need to choose your like um content
management system you know you need to
choose your plugins you need to like
choose that SEO optimization and you
need to like pay for it sometimes in
addition you have to like you have to
win over you too or Google like if you
want to communicate with your audience
you have to like set that up yourself
like you need to have a mailing list and
then send it for people to sign up for
your mailing listen I acknowledge that
that is from what everyone says like the
most valuable thing that's more valuable
than people clicking the bell because
then you know you have their email
addresses
even if YouTube goes away and you can
still be like hey guys
YouTube's not around anymore so this is
where we post and stuff now but like
it's so much more work to do that
obviously it's costly yeah it's costly
yeah it cost money to do that kind of
stuff and the bigger you got the more it
costs so but also I mean if you look at
our data the reason why we're getting so
many views is mainly because of YouTube
yep No
we love all of our subscribers we love
everyone who has that Bell turned on but
honestly 11 percent its 11 percent of
our subscribers have that Bell 11
percent of subscribers have have that
Bell ticked but the majority the vast
majority of our views come from YouTube
suggesting it yeah nonsubscribers
nonsubscribers yeah and if so if it
wasn't for that we would have a very
small fraction maybe 11 percent of the
amount of views we have now and that's
like a good way to compare it to and
that's that's a weakness and a power we
are at the mercy of YouTube continuing
to like find us like attractive and
sometimes that stresses us out every now
and then we'll have like a major
existential crisis about like are we
doing this wrong are we doing this wrong
what if 10 years from now YouTube's gone
and like we didn't invest in our website
enough and we never got a mailing list
and well we'll go through like appear a
short period of like oh god we have to
go go excess now and then Evan I'll put
like an afternoon into research and use
like no no no I don't want you to but
ever it's fine you know we'll fill you
really care will stick with us if if
there are being issues we'll figure them
out as we get there then we come back
let's not invent trouble yeah it's not
invent trouble and it's not like
anything is gonna shift like that I
think that we're gonna see signs we're
gonna see trends and and you know we'll
be able to like get out one last shout
into whatever like social media platform
we need you to move to the next one or
what have you you know it's like also
interestingly one thing that like makes
you feel more relaxed about
transitioning is our experience with
tik-tok like I know people have mixed
feelings about Tech Talk we're not
saying go there there are concerns about
tik-tok what you know know what have you
but one thing that I think that just
from an experience of growth over there
we never posted about it on YouTube we
never posted about it on any of our
social with you guys stream which are
like our smaller audience smaller
audiences and that's our second-biggest
platform we're bigger on tick-tock the
only platform we have those bigger than
tick-tock is our main channel and pretty
soon one of our art pieces of content on
tick-tock is gonna be our most viewed
piece of content ever yep more than
YouTube after putting in not that much
time and effort into it over like a few
months yeah so it's like that actually
makes me relieved honestly it's like
yeah just kind of like figure things out
as you go and like in transition if we
need to and and I don't know okay I'm
gonna tell ya that we're getting
distracted we're going on top tangent I
forgot to go on another tangent go for
it okay so yeah this is fun this is
awful we talked about this guys we
talked about this stuff all the time
this is like it's what we live and
breathe and we don't want to like we
don't like chat about with you guys
we don't mystery type stuff but like
we're hitting the highlights of
everything here like some of our best
are more interesting or more like the
big picture things we talk about nuance
stuff all the time oh man hey okay so
here's the thing and this is gonna go
back to um again how like I have heard
not that I necessarily like agree or
disagree or whatever but I have heard
the sentiment of like Oh our blogs dead
is that you know it has video content
taken over here's an interesting thing
Instagram is lawyer isn't I don't know
if it's out yet I think it's maybe out
with a select group of people yes not us
we just saw an article about it they're
like rolling out a feature that is
essentially blog posts yeah in Instagram
in its again what is call just so weird
it feels like going full circle because
so many I ever heard from so many
bloggers that like a lot of times their
main audience is now on Instagram like
they have a bigger they're more people
following them on Instagram than they do
going to their blog and Instagram is
like the portal through which people get
to
Blagh but yeah it's just interesting it
feels like it's going fools full circle
almost yeah so it's like I have I have
one that I found like that that you know
we have like a news thing of like
industry news and yeah there's a there's
a featured image with a title and then
there's written information and then an
image and then more riding in an image
and more riding in an image but it's
like it's basically a blog post within
Instagram which is crazy and honestly
one strength of blogs that I really like
is you are in full control over
everything you can start with an image
do text you can have videos multiple
videos one video multiple videos what
have you you can tell whatever story
you're trying to tell and whatever way
you want to talk you can embed it you
can embed like a podcast yeah you can do
your full control over everything which
is so nice on the blog and that's kinda
nice and like one thing that we've kind
of been enjoying like I didn't intends
to plug this but over on patreon
sometimes we'll ride up big almost like
blog posts with words like image riding
image riding image riding and that's
that's a great way to tell some stories
yeah yeah that's that's kind of like
where we've channeled our past like blog
energy obviously if Instagram just
didn't put these in a separate place and
you could like click in on like a post
and it could be a blog post I don't know
I don't know if you like held your thumb
over it yeah you know like prolonged
expanded in I don't know but anyways
it's just fascinating that it's adding a
like blog e-type feature I don't know
where that's gonna lead I mean probably
what they're trying to do is just keep
people from clicking off of Instagram
honestly because like right now people
want to share more photos and media and
text than what you can fit in an
Instagram post they're linking away also
I think instagrams is trying to get
people to stay on well it wasn't
Facebook do that or something you know
like the Facebook has to read more like
then you can have your first image and
then text and just do inline images you
know the heck this might already exist
on Facebook we're just too behind the
times because
you might Facebook is like oh we can
talk about Facebook for a while the hot
mess of Facebook we'll save that for
later yeah I have I have things to say
so one one thing about blogs that I did
feel a little bit of nostalgia for yeah
um that not that we couldn't do this on
YouTube but we won't do this on YouTube
is like blogs were so much more
real-time and flexible like like we
could do a giant mega blog post about a
huge project and then the next few posts
could be like tiny little mini posts
that were just like oh I am I picked up
some tiles for the laundry room it's not
even installing the tiles it's just like
I picked them out and there's a whole
blog post or it could be like a ten-part
series that spread out across six months
and you know you kind of develop your
own like playlists where people can like
if they get there after it's done they
can easily find all the posts but it was
just so much more flexible and I felt
like you could post about much smaller
things like we won that's just like we
put swatches on the wall paint swatches
on the wall for the laundry room and
share our feelings the feelings the
paint swatches that was it those
literally it and like it was interesting
too because often times in our blog post
we would post about the project and then
like venture off and almost like a vlog
type thing we talked about
yeah it was very vlog II there's a lot
of updates about wedding planning and
vacations but I like the projects and
also our feelings or experiences like I
wrote a whole post about like experience
like like issues with contractors
experiences around that you know and it
was that is one of the like I think good
things about blogs is you you could be a
lot more flexible because it wasn't tied
to an algorithm that like oh maybe it
prioritizes views before and now it's
prioritizing watch time it's not like
Google prioritizes you know how
I don't know IIIi don't wanna say
anything let's not true maybe they do
prioritize how long someone stays on
okay versus knows like we never fully
succeeded on the blog so we were just
having fun and doing whatever just
because there's no maybe that's why I'm
like oh man if we just had time to do
Evan and Caitlin - stuff that'd be so
fun cuz there's no stakes yeah like you
don't care if ya flops but but we've
held on to that with our gaming channel
you know we don't stress that much about
a channel that's true and like we don't
put as much pressure on the thumbnails
and that's job titles and stuff that's
more what I'm nostalgic for mm-hmm but I
don't know it was just blogs had a very
nice real-time kind of vlog II feel to
them at least like ours did and the ones
that I read did which as the person
riding it is is nice like like I enjoyed
riding that style but also as a reader
you really did feel like you were
following along with someone and it
wasn't like here's my like uh weekly
vlog that I put out scheduled every
Friday not that there's anything wrong
with that but it feels less real-time
than like back when people were doing
the daily vlogs it was a lot harder to
do a daily vlog than it is like a daily
blog post I think every now again we're
speaking yeah from a place of like
speculation now Calum yes it's gonna be
hard to equate YouTube and blogging
because our experiences with YouTube
have been so different yes and we've
found success there but if we had a
super successful blog that was
equivalent to our YouTube channel in
terms of opportunities and engagement
and fun things and stuff like that verse
YouTube which would you enjoy the
process of creating more YouTube really
what did that what are the main things
so I kind of I took a similar role in in
both and I you kind of have a similar
role in both were like you would kind of
do more of the like practical design
work and research for projects and I
would kind of craft the story so like I
did the writing
I do the editing on the videos and one
thing that brings me joy is like trying
to make things funny and entertaining
and I feel like it is easier and more
fun for me to do that in video form than
it is for a blog post like writing was
never like a strength of mine in school
it wasn't something that I was like
particularly drawn to as a hobby not
that like editing was either but I feel
like there's so many more times run it
where I like crack myself up yeah I'm
editing and I'm probably just like with
my head not always so impatient because
like Kaitlyn has something funny
yeah-ah me she like it's not ready yet
it's like it's like she's like cooking
like it's not ready it's too hot I
haven't added the spices yet that's
exactly it yeah added spices and I also
just I don't know I enjoyed the process
of like video more than I do taking
photos and writing now
I do have to add a caveat to this okay
when we first started doing YouTube
videos it wasn't as fun to film or at it
trail because we were doing things that
didn't that we felt good about but we
weren't fully they would they weren't
the most natural fit for the two of us
and the two of us have fun in like like
we are in the middle of filming a video
right now it is like oh it's so fun it
was fast easy fun all these good things
you know it's like I'm like oh yeah what
is this coming out is that gonna be out
around it won't it won't be out yet okay
anyways good and like this is the
perfect fit for us the filming was easy
the editing like is so natural like so
many funny moments the best now
contrasting that to the blogging it's
not like a one-to-one comparison
we weren't doing as fun stuff that's
true we would laugh as much from my
perspective blogging was easier and less
pressure than filming mm-hmm so there's
that but it also wasn't this fun yeah
yeah yeah I think like I don't know in
some ways it's kind of like live
streaming our games like we both enjoy
gaming yes but there's something about
like live streaming it that makes it
even more fun like knowing that we're
sharing it with someone and for the blog
post what you're sharing is the photos
and then you write about the experience
later but that's different than
capturing the experience in the moment
and knowing like Oh somebody's really
gonna get to like watch this and hang
out with us like it gives it a joy it's
a drag yeah
blogging it because the creation of the
content of like the storytelling came so
much after yeah the actual project in a
way like it was separate from it it
wasn't that same kind of like giddy fun
that we sometimes can get with like
streaming and videos yeah
so for the two of us like so so do it we
were going to do the project either way
and in the process of the project we
either capture the project in video
where so much as capture the moment or
wait is document it with photos and then
write up the experience later and for
the two of us video is the more natural
fit for that because for all of our
lives like I'm not sure if like this
like this is right word but like like my
my parents called like me like a little
bit of a ham ham oh yeah we would like
perform for the camera we would like
that aspect of like time spent we like
hamming it up in a way you do we enjoy
it it is fun for us it's an enjoyable
thing and other people don't like that
yeah other people don't like
that aspect of like the project took us
a while to get used to because it is
different like filming yourself no
you're gonna put on the Internet
versus like you know we used to do like
little vacation videos just for
ourselves
yeah that we never plan to put anywhere
you know so it it still took us a while
to get used to doing like filming
ourselves for internet consumption but I
definitely think it is a better fit for
us and I think that that that
interestingly we have kind of been on a
journey here personally for a long time
we have been wanting to create content
we've been wanting to share it we've
been wanting to put it out there and
we've tried all different forms blogging
was one of the steps along the way and I
don't think that we would have gotten to
a YouTube channel without the blog hanky
and we learned so much from the blog but
it is for us wasn't the best fit but you
know I think that like that content and
that contact form is still working for
so many people there are still so many
blogs that are doing well and some for
some people it's the perfect fit you
know what with the right set of talents
and like personalities etc you know it
is interesting them um like you know we
obviously right now we're not going into
the events but back when we were going
to events there's some events that we go
to in the like DIY makerspace where
there are youtubers and there are
bloggers and there are instagramers you
know there's people who like their
primary thing is like various on various
different types of platforms and it's so
interesting because the youtubers are
like like so how how important do you
think you know to the bloggers like how
important is it that I have a website
like do I need to be pinning stuff like
yeah like Scheinman mailing this all the
bloggers are like yes oh my gosh
like that's my lifeblood you have to do
these you're not on a premium ad serving
network that serves the better paying
ads all right like how are you doing
this you're not putting ads in the
middle of your blog post what are you
doing doing so much on the table but
then also all the bloggers are like do I
need to start a YouTube channel just a
video and we're like yeah - if
not oh my gosh you're doing these
projects already it's a waste not to
video document them and it's like
neither of us are wrong or right it's
just so interesting like it's too much
work for like a single party to do a
full-time blog and a full-time YouTube
channel unless they have like a whole
team of people working for them and it's
just funny that there's like FOMO on
either side of it yeah I know where I
know are leaving a lot on the table by
not like happily investing on Pinterest
but it's just like I'd rather just make
another video I just think it's
interesting that it's like we're both
trying to trying to do our own like
independent you know business building
our brand and all this stuff on
different platforms and we're like are
we leaving stuff on the table that
you're doing and they're like are you am
i leaving stuff on the table that you
were doing I think it just like I'm
gonna go back to a story I've told
multiple times so I apologize if you all
have already heard it listening but we
were at a conference and we were giving
it a a panel talk with five other
youtubers successful youtubers some with
millions and millions of subscribers
more than we had at the time and all
five of us had different views on just
YouTube where we're talking about like
blogging and YouTube right now but also
like everyone's YouTube experience it's
everyone's blog experience is different
but like yeah we were on stage all but
one person we're all like maker slash
education slash DIY related yeah and
then and we were like do this and the
other person's like no do this and
another person's like this is important
other friends like that's not important
at all don't worry about it so it's like
with content creation there's still such
a new things there are no hard and fast
rules everyone's making it up as you go
there are some things that work for some
people I don't really know why I'm
getting into all of this but I think
that since we've been talking about
YouTube versus blogs and we've been
talking about things that work for us
yeah yeah with with this we're just
sharing our personal experiences we're
not sharing any hard and fast rules
about
anything yeah yeah we just think again
like Evan mentioned this is the kind of
stuff we'd love to have to talk about it
well the thing we can't share is we
analyze other channels oh yeah oh all
those we love like saying like what do
you think about their drift cuz like one
thing that's really to me it's like not
just where people are at best in the
moment we don't like like their friends
watching watching the single video is
interesting but watching a channel
develop so Emma's grow like which way
are they moving is it through intent or
is it through following the views or is
it just like listen listening to good
advice listen to bad advice are they
doing this intentionally or are they
just getting tired of this and they're
just not doing that as much or maybe
they're changing their personalities as
they grow and stuff very fascinating to
analyze oh and I don't want to we don't
want to mention these specific channels
just because like it's the only good
feeling in the drama and weird in
everything we don't do it for the
purpose of like drama we do it for the
purpose of learning like it's it's
fascinating for us to see the trends of
either people that have come before us
or people that kind of like came up at
the same time as us and it's just
interesting like one thing that I can
generalize and then relate to us that's
one thing that we can do there's a
complete side tangent this could almost
be as a podcast in the making but like
one thing that we tried to look out for
and worried about because we've seen it
happen to other channels you you start
leaning into what you're being praised
for to the point where you go beyond
your base and you're almost like a
parody of whether you started yeah you
know it's like you know you get praised
for this one thing that you do and you
do it like too much and you do it that's
all your channel is and then you've lost
what made people fall in love with you
in the beginning which was the contrast
between normal and this one thing and
then there's all is one thing and then
it's too much
you know stuff like that so like an
example might be like okay so we have a
couple like little songs that we do have
like resin time or science adjacent and
we get good feedback about those we
could we could lean into that because we
get good feedback you know people want
merch with those things on them like we
so many comments are due to resin type
um we could really lean into that and
make a song for literally every type of
project we do every type of thing so
that like in every video there's gonna
be at least four songs it is time to use
the modifier
we're gonna deep I'm doing the same tune
but we don't want to be one-dimensional
like that we want to keep on doing new
things we don't want to get stuck inside
of things like or like a lot of our
views are around resin a lot of people
like you should just do resin right but
if we don't want to be one-dimensional
like that even though we love we love
resin but we still like purposely mixin
other projects that aren't resin related
just cuz we don't want to get stuck just
doing that or like you know we we want
to keep mixing it up or like on the
gaming channel minecraft like it's our
longest lar longest series we just did
part 50 yeah if we had them just stuck
with minecraft we might not have found
we might not have a forest or animal
crossing other games and that we really
loved love yeah and so yeah it's it's
it's easy to lean too far into something
you're getting praised for yeah and then
like either get yourself in a situation
with viewer expectations that you can't
get out of or just like be too much that
or you get tied to it
you can't escape and you fatigue of it
and you end up not liking it anymore
but you still have to do it and you're
doing it anyways I think we're getting
off track which which means that it's
time to to wrap this up and move on to
things beacon
nothing else should should we should we
look at anything else we can look at our
notes but I think we covered all the
stuff that I want to talk about yeah
yeah I think so too
we did we did good good job Caitlin good
job this is this has been a really
interesting topic to span two different
podcasts Wow so thank you guys for
hanging out with us okay now that it's
time for thing of the week
I knew that you wanted they'll leave
room for the music I sensed your I
sensed your mood Caleb I also like
sometimes you sound like you're leading
into the outrun I'm like if you sound
like you're leading to outro people are
gonna leave boom so people can see the
progress bar thing of the weeks of 10
minutes yeah but they can't always see
the progress bar you know maybe if
they're about to exit they usually see
the bruising on their on their
headphones posit happen I know I'm done
like Evans wrap it up cuz he's saying
thank you everyone for listening and
watching and they're like okay it's done
alright my thing of the week are doing
to go first I saw my thing of the week
is it's not really a thing it's a live
act as a tip I learned now I'm not
service on Apple so you might need to
look it up but on Windows you can press
the Windows key and then the semicolon
and that pulls up an emoji keyboard on
your matter where you are on your
computer yeah we use emojis a lot yeah
because you know communicating on the
internet through just text not enough
not enough and also often times it's
easy to miss communicate I want Smiley's
I want emotions
I want the surprise face I want the
hands in the air yeah I want smiles
thumbs ups yeah that's how we talk and
we talk and we like you know we also use
them a lot on social media a ton we we
still like we've mentioned earlier we
still replied a lot of comments and and
almost all of our revised with emojis
yeah and so we use emojis a lot um so
that was just like like a little like
yeah if you're on on your computer
didn't you do it accidentally I did it
accidentally I was like trying to type
or something I accidentally pressed
Windows semicolon and then I was like
well how'd that emoji keyboard then come
up and then I googled it I found it and
windows semicolon so if if there is an
Apple equivalent I'm assuming it would
be Apple semicolon probably not I don't
know like Apple is doing its own thing
who knows who knows okay so my thing of
the week is a series of books series I
just finished that Evan had recommended
to me and it's called the heart striker
series
and I really liked it there is a five
five part series and apparently there's
like another three part series in the
same world I haven't started here yeah
but you're going to I'm very excited but
it's kind of like a modern fantasy like
modern-day kind of fantasy where
basically the premise is like you know
we we were all going about our daily
lives and then a mysterious meteor hit
the earth and it like really in modern
day then all these things where were
you're woken like mages and spirits and
Dragons and like all this craziness um
so it's kind of like the world it's set
in but the reason I like it is like
there's it's super fast pace which is
important because I get bored easily in
bux super fast paced very interesting
characters and very like deep back
stories but back stories that are
revealed little by little as you
continue through the book so it might
the characters might seem like a little
one-dimensional at first but everything
is revealed in a very natural way over
time which I prefer over like having to
read a giant back chapter on just this
one back story past thing yeah like it's
all world they make you care about a
person and then they give them give them
a full chapter later with the backstory
once you're like invested in them but
they they like developed the story which
spans centuries like very naturally and
within a very fast-paced serious you can
tell that the author came up with the
full story arc and then broke it up and
divided it between the books and
everything like that there is no like I
mean I could just talk about some books
here he's like oh well books 2 and 3
sucks oh my gosh every book was great
don't even get me started on sort of
truth don't even get me started on Wheel
of Time those have some those had some
dry periods you just have to slog
through it with the heart Straker series
everything was primo the ending was very
satisfying it is like a light book it's
a nice
like this book yeah not fluffy it's
pretty fluffy it's pretty fun fluffy
movie but it's got interesting
characters and like interesting stories
it's an interesting take you're
constantly on a cliffhanger constantly a
cliffhanger yeah yeah I liked a lot and
it's all have a link to it yeah alright
guys well thank you again for tuning in
to our little podcast here on this our
little corner of the Internet
appreciate you guys hanging out with us
hope you're having a great day wherever
you are whatever you're doing and we
look forward to seeing you in the next
one oh wait do I add a thing go for it
I'm gonna we'll probably have a couple
reminders for this but we mentioned it
like in passing in the Pat in the last
podcast but we want to do a thing where
we have people submit we want to do like
a enk advice column and we also are
interested in doing like en que spooky
stories so we're gonna have a link in in
here and in the description where you
can submit those types of things and we
think it'd be super fun to like read
them and react to them on the podcast so
just want to throw that in there will
probably mention it a few more times
both times have been like at the end of
the podcast and then a very quick aside
we're still trying to figure it all out
exactly you know it can even though I
might have been talking like those end
of the podcast the end of podcast music
wasn't playing oh yeah that's do you
know yeah when you hear that this music
that's playing right now that's when you
know it's that yeah true true listeners
understand yes look for to seeing here
being with you next time I already used
um I wanted Joe emergency exit emergency
exit